[موسيقى]
اخذ هذا الحدث مجراه كل سنه لاكثر من سته
عقود ولكن هذا العام تم استقبال مسابقه
ملكه جمال العالم بعارضه قويه وتشكل
اغلبيه عدد سكان اندونيسيا من المسلمين
وتم اختيار عاصمتها جاكارتا لاستضافه
الحدث الذي يمتد لثلاثه اسابيع لكن
الاحتجاجات من قبل جماعات اسلاميه ادت الى
تبديل المكان في اللحظه الاخيره واضطر
المنظمون للانتقال الى منتجع جزيره بالي
هذا يرسل رساله الى العالم باننا لسنا
بدوله
قويه وندد المتظاهرون بان المسابقه تعد
اباحيه ومسابقه للعاهرات مصرين على انها
مهينه للمسلمين
اجمعين اعتبرها مسابقه لاستغلال
النساء وفي محاوله لتهدئه المخاوف الامنيه
الغى القائمون على هذه المسابقه فقره
ملابس البكيني واستبدلتها بثياب مناسبه
للبحر
[موسيقى]
ومن مسابقات الجمال الحائزه على اعجاب
الشعب استضافت اندونيسيا مسابقه جمال
المسلمات قبل بضعه اسابيع وتم تتويج
نيجيريه كملكه لجمال
المسلمات بينما تحاول اندونيسيا الظهور في
صوره الانفتاح والتسامح يظهر تاثير
الاسلاميين المتشددين النامي في البلاد
ويقول المنتقدون ان الحكومه تزيد من هذه
المشكله بالانقياد خلف مطالب المسلمين
المتشددين
وتؤخذ التهديدات ضد المسابقه على محمل
الجد فقد اصدرت الولايات المتحده والسفاره
البريطانيه وال الاستراليه تحذيرات بعد
تفجيرات بالي عام 2002 و25 والتي لا تزال
عالقه في اذهان
الناس في بالي وتحت الحراسه الامنيه
المشدده تؤكد السلطات انها لن تجازف حيث
تم تعيين 700 شرطي لحمايه الفائزه بلقب
ملكه جمال
العالم
i